any self-respecting Pixar fan could tell
you that the animation company's movies
are filled with references and easter
eggs of its back catalogue but producer
mark Nielsen has admitted that there's
nods to every single Pixar movie in Toy
Story 4 we're going to be exploring them
in 3 2 1
as usual we will be issuing a spoiler
alert because we're about to be
revealing some details from the film the
movie opens with a flashback to 9 years
ago
explaining the absence of Bo Peep from
Toy Story 3 she was last spotted singing
with Woody Buzz Jessie and Weezy in Toy
Story 2 but fans complained that it
wasn't clear whether she'd been broken
or was donated outside the license plate
on the car is our Mr F 97 license plates
have been used in cars and Toy Story 2
to mean a whole range of things this one
refers to when Toy Story 2 was
accidentally deleted from Pixar's
Edit system or MRF 97 was the command on
the computer that deleted the film which
had to be restored using a backup file
Bo Peep assist woody in rescuing RC from
a storm drain a card is passed through
the group to use as a launch pad on this
card is a crude drawing of rainbow
unicorn from inside out human fairy
dream adventure part 7 are a toy take a
closer look at the boxes at the back of
the classroom when Bonnie creates four
key one of them belongs to Anton a
possible reference to food critic Anton
ego in ratatouille
Bonnie's room has some similarities to
the wallpaper in Andy's room in Toy
Story and later in the film we see a
bedspread full of Pizza Planet styled
rockets that are the same as in the
original movie
the van that the family goes on vacation
in is a tri-county RV this links to
references to tri-county International
Airport in Toy Story 2 and Troy County
Landfill in Toy Story 3 one of the
vacation spots is a home that looks
eerily similar to The Incredibles house
wood in folky come across second-chance
antiques the store sign tells us that it
was established in 1986 the same year as
Pixar also the building address is 1 2 0
0 now Pixar is based at 1 2 0 0 Park
Avenue Emeryville California outside the
antique store is a ship removal span
this same company van crops up in Toy
Story of terror inside the store is
where we get lots of movie references
packed in there's a vintage record from
chalupa records from Coco
there's a green divers mask and Tiki
heads from the fish tank in Finding Nemo
bo-peep slide past a plate that has an
ornate looking symbol from brave in it
this plate could be seen in several
shots a yellow plane hanging mid window
resembles Sunwing from planes there are
also awards cases from Gusto's office in
ratatouille and furniture from The
Incredibles take a closer look at the
key that the antique store staff member
is holding it looks very much like
Sora's Keyblade from Kingdom Hearts fans
have speculated that this is a nod to
the upcoming Square Enix title Kingdom
Hearts 3 the antagonists from the
antique store are a group of vintage
toys the ventriloquist dummy Vincent
wears of resemblance to slappy the dummy
from goosebumps and Gaby Gaby has the
same yellow bows and dress as Chatty
Cathy from the 1960s here's where the
shading comes in from carpets to garbage
truck license plates Stanley Kubrick's
film has made an appearance in many toy
story movies a record is put on playing
midnight the stars and you
as performed by Ray noble and his
orchestra this is the same song as
played at the end of the shining as the
camera pans out from a photograph
showing Jack smiling at the Overlook
Hotel ball fans have also suggested that
the old lady's home address when
attacked by ducky and bunny is 2 3 7 so
keep an eye out for that
combat Carl is back we see a combat cold
of being blown up by Sid in the first
Toy Story this version though is too
cold weathers look-alike from Toy Story
of terror rumor has it that John
Lasseter wants to use a GI Joe doll in
the original movie but Hasbro was upset
that the doll will be blown up so they
agreed to make up a brand instead buzz
flies into a purple and yellow spider
like roid that has the same color
palette as surg his enemy in Toy Story 2
there's a spinning ride next to the
ferris wheel with a purple and yellow
umbrella structure this looks exactly
like the Sun drop flower from tangled
a stone is called Jetstream echoing the
character alias strut Jetstream it's in
this fairground that Bo Peep loses her
arm
throughout Disney owned franchises
counters lose an arm in a nod to Luke
Skywalker's amputation scene at the end
of the Empire Strikes Back
both sheep bring her a bottle cap and a
safety pin while out foraging the cat
they give her is for the same grape soda
bottle in up later in the film buzz gets
trapped in a ring toss doll game other
prizes include the guitars from Koko
Rockets featuring the Pixar ball and a
red and yellow stuffed toy flame
resembling anger and inside out think
chika boom looks a bit familiar
he actually cropped up in Incredibles -
lying in the corner of Jack Jack's crib
bow and woody approached the secret
entrance for a club in the antique store
above this we see a decoration for
cattles bruised after Ed Catmull the
long-standing studio exec who's stepping
down after Toy Story 4 Bo presses a
$0.25 button on the slot machine she
went to the club the number 25 pops up a
few times in the film this could be a
nod to the Toy Story 3 maker the
Elkridge who's stepping down a Pixar
after 25 years in 2019 inside the club
we meet tin toy from the 1988 pixar
short tin toy and the Eagle from Toy
Story toons so think mr. Potato Head
sounds familiar don rickles his voice is
actually in the movie despite the fact
that the actor died in 2017 he had
signed on to the movie before his death
and his vocal likeness was compiled
through barrier shorts games and theme
park voiceovers and yes we found a 1 1 3
it's a door number from the California
Institute of Arts and it's a number that
crops up in nearly every single Pixar
movie
also did you spot Dinoco gas the RV stop
sir it's the same chain of gas stations
that Woody and Buzz get stranded at in
the original Toy Story look closer at
the poster for the movie and you'll see
a reference to up a painting hangs on
the wall behind the gang of dogs platon
poker the same dogs that Russel sail
past holding a bunch of balloons think
he's four so anything that we missed
comment below
you